i kind of need you to be quiet though
okay go ahead all right great so i'm
going to just send this out on
online see if we're actually live it
should be live
pretty quickly and it'll be quite
thrilling to welcome a live audience to
chat with you
i i know you've done this in the past
but uh
but uh this is a little bit different
kind of audience we have a
scientifically
engineering-minded audience which fits
very well with your background
i'm talking to bill perkins he is the
author of
die with zero which is uh an uplifting
book
despite what you may think of the title
the book is extremely
uplifting to me and actually i think it
fits in really nicely with some of the
themes we talk about here
on the arthur c clarke center for human
imaginations
into the impossible podcast welcome bill
perkins you were on a boat somewhere you
don't have a landline connecting you to
shore do you
uh no no we we we're going wi-fi with
duke
engel technology here oh that's awesome
so we're in the virgin islands
uh in christmas cove oh wow okay warm
weather oh nice
uh that's great so yeah it's uh it's a
great pleasure to be here i just wanted
to give a shout out to our mutual friend
james altucher who is uh one of the
people who gives the
uh encomium or the uh the props to you
on the back of the book here
he says about this book um
that it's uh that it's life-changing and
he agrees with kevin hart comedian kevin
hart who says die with zero opens up a
completely different avenue
of thinking so that your life can be
maximized through memorable experiences
why wait and bill you might be wondering
why are you talking to a scientist
although you are an engineer and i know
that you're trained in engineering
but uh the first thing i want to say is
do you know what albert einstein's
said was the greatest invention of the
human mind
no i give me give me a guess because i
have all these false quotes by einstein
like compound interest
you know which what is it he said it he
said compound interest is the greatest
invention of the human mind and
of course this is somebody who invented
relativity coined the word the photon
did all sorts of things but i think it's
uh i think it's apt and your book really
made me think about compound interest
not with money uh but with uh regard to
memories and i first want to ask you
what uh can you say something about the
book describe it for my audience don't
give away the goods
although you give away so much value in
this book including
uh free worksheets that i've worked on
and filled out
and uh and a mailing list that people
can subscribe to but first just give me
the 10 second overview
how how will this book change other
people's lives the way it's changed my
life already
okay so one of the things to to when you
think about our lives as human beings
we we die and we deteriorate and because
we die and we
deteriorate that implicates what we do
today
a lot of people think oh you know you
heard the question what would you do if
you're going to die tomorrow
right but what were you going to do if
you die 10 days from now
so basically what you do today is kind
of like this integral right backwards
integral
of your death date and the rate of your
deterioration
and you know you're a scientist you
model
when you model things you tend to get
them right or closer to right
right and so this book is really about
modeling your life from now wherever you
are
to the grave so that you optimize and
solve for maximum
fulfillment that's what the book is it's
a modeling book
yeah and it's about resources and it's
about conversion of resources
and the fungibility of resources that
people don't think about i tweeted out
to my
uh to my microscopic fan base today that
this uh medallion this nobel prize
medallion
is really the result of a failed estate
plan according to
none other than than bill perkins um
because alfred nobel left all his money
he never married he had no kids
he left all his money to endow this
prize only after he died
and uh it's grown much much more slowly
than compound interest on other
investments might grow
so i wonder you know people look at this
as as sort of
uh the ultimate thing to aspire to in
science this is chocolate so you know i
could eat this
but uh but that's not a real one i don't
have one and after writing my book
losing the nobel prize
i certainly won't get one but i want to
start with another book about death
and this book is called denial of death
and it's by ernest becker
and i should say that this book a bill i
i need a guy like you in my lab
because it's impeccably researched i
read all the footnotes
i didn't find a single typo in this book
i know you uh
you put a lot of effort and energy into
it i just want to salute that but the
footnotes are golden my friend thank you
so much for including
such a well-researched book you know i
had i had a good team we worked with
people to make sure that
you know there's going to be people
you're trying to get this message
out to the maximum audience right
because it fits everyone everyone can
everyone's you know trying to have a
fulfilling life right an adventurous
life or
however they define it and i wanted to
give them the mental models to make sure
that they were able to do it but if they
reject the idea outright
right well the data doesn't show this or
i'm going to wind up you know if i use
all my resources and allocate my
resources in this place
then i didn't play insurance agent for
myself at 65 and then i'm going to need
all this money at 65 and i have to have
the data that shows
old people don't spend money yeah you
know i'm just gonna i'm just gonna cut
to the chase i'm not gonna be polite i'm
not gonna whatever
you you can't you don't spend the money
my theory is they can't
right their temperament has changed
their abilities have changed
their health has changed and
they are sitting on stacks of of
resources that they exchanged hours of
their life
for to never use yeah right and i say
you know
delayed gratification at its extreme is
no gratification
and so i want to make sure that people
allocate their resources properly
throughout their life to get the most
out of it
yeah i i couldn't agree more and part of
your training as an engineer must have
included risk
modeling risk management and mitigation
and i think about that all the time
people think oh you're a cosmologist you
spend your time
looking up at the heavens i spend about
one percent of my time looking at the
heavens and the rest of my time
thinking about all the ways something
can go wrong in the quest to do that
and most people think about um either
it's impossible and even you
at it to give to be a little bit uh
contrarian here
even you say it's impossible to die with
zero uh of course it is
exactly to you know two of the penny but
on the other hand
i would wonder you know in terms of risk
management would you
err on the side of dying with what
negative one dollar
or uh or or positive a million dollars
yeah i i mean i i think i i demonstrate
in the book
how the more fulfilling life right of
your choosing right
however you want to live it is to shoot
for the negative dollar
right or negative ten dollars right that
is the that is going to get
that's going to bring you closer to the
optimal
life of your that you're able to have
right of your design
right so i don't tell people how to live
like you should do this or you can go
here it's not a cookbook right
it's a model on how to take your money
your health and your time those
resources that you have throughout your
life in varying degrees
and and and get the most out of them
yeah right and it's it's about
application of resources when it matters
you talk very touchingly about your
daughters
and wanting to watch a winnie the pooh
huffle up movie and they wanted to watch
it probably more than you when you were
a young man earning your earning your
way and and
and yet when you wanted to watch it it
was too late they didn't want to watch
it with you anymore talk a little bit
about that vignette because it was so it
was very moving to me personally i've
got daughters i've got sons
it was very moving to me talk about how
that felt when you had that realization
we can't now they're teenagers so tell
let me tell you they don't wanna they
don't wanna see me at all right now so
they've gone to the dark side of the
moon i don't know how they did it but
they went
there um the the concept is this is that
you know we all know that a lot of
people have this nebulous date
in the future when we're gonna die right
they understand deterioration it's still
far off but
what we don't realize is that there's
seasons of our life right
that come and go and pass us by and
certain experiences
choices decisions whatever you want to
call them are meant for those periods
they're not transferable to another
period and i i uh
the story i use is with my kids you know
having young kids that'll want to watch
a disney pooh half a lung movie with you
sit there and hold your hand
this sweet endearing story that time is
going to come to an
end i don't get a a flag that says
you know 30 seconds so that period is
going to end but it does pass and so
that experience of watching that movie
with my my
youngest daughter brisa came and went
and so if i didn't get all my poo
heffalump watches in
during that period i'm not getting any
more right and and that's just one
example but there's you know you
you're a young single person you're in
your 20s you're a college student
you're you're you're you're married you
have young kids you're you know
you're a businessman like we all have
different seasons in our life in
different periods
of which we are to allocate certain
experiences
where they're best enjoyed yeah and
once that season pass they're either
difficult to transfer to another period
or impossible yeah right and you know
the easy ones that are impossible is
like look i'm
i have a degenerative uh cartilage in my
back
skiing for me in 75 is seems unlikely
you know technology may come along et
cetera but it seems like if i don't
spend my ski dollars now i have wasted
my ski dollars
they need to be allocated to something
else problem is is
as you deteriorate right the number of
activities and experiences you're able
to
convert your money into positive life
experiences
that conversion gets less and less and
less and less and less and less
right it's like that the resistance goes
it's like resistance in in
in a wire right as it goes up to
infinity the older you get the higher
the resistance goes
for your ability to convert your money
into positive experiences and that's why
that's one of the reasons why we see it
so hard
for older people of all wealth grades
to accumulate their assets and convert
them into experiences
right yeah and i think what's so
interesting is that we and my channel is
not only for technically-minded people
but it's
a wide variety of audience members
comprise the
the the subscriber base but many of them
are technically minded and yet
i find they they spend almost the least
amount of time
thinking about the end of their life and
what they're going to do and
the simple realization that hit me like
a ton of bricks
uh from your book was that there's
basically this optimization problem it's
a mini max or maximin problem
that you can do a calculus problem one
of my listeners has already she's
already gotten the idea
church of entropy she's saying it's a
calculus problem if you drop a trillion
dollars
on my little newborn kid it's not going
to do anything for her
if you drop a trillion dollars on my
aging grandfather he's not going to do
anything with it on his deathbed
so that means there's an optimum a 40
year old a 30 year old they could do a
lot
and so i i find your book uh so uh so
useful because it's counterintuitive
there's also another curve you can
overlay and i'm working on some models
of this i was
doing some coding it was so much fun but
you already did this for me
so i don't need to do it you've got an
app that you can link to and i'll have i
have in the show notes a link to your uh
to your awesome website
you have a tool to go through this it's
not for billionaires alone
because all of us will have a maximum
utility value of a dollar
at some point in their life it's a date
it's not an amount as you point out it's
not an amount so there'll be some day
when a dollar is worth
the maximum value to you uh out there
listening
and uh and there'll be a day that that
correlates to in terms of your health
can you spend it on hiking the alps no
not when you're 90.
so i think that that is really driven
and i want to ask you
psychologically do you think it's
psychologically the fear
of running out of money and not being
able to bounce the check to the
undertaker
that causes people not to die with zero
and to die with huge wasted resource of
the time value of money what is the
number one
cause that people don't die with zero i
think i think it's pork cultural and
autopilot so culture is another word for
autopilot like you get into a culture
and these are the things the way it's
done you know think about it whatever
you just go on go to your job punch the
clock
call home watch your sports etc you're
not thinking about when i'm gonna die
how am i going to allocate my time
would it you know what do i really want
right like you got
good at something most of us got good at
something in order to survive
put food shelter and water right and
then we developed habits to get even
better
at that right and protecting ourselves
and we have little vacations etc but we
really don't think about like hey
what is the arc of my life gonna look
like from cradle to grave
what does my health look like at this
point and what does the deterioration of
my body look like
from wherever i'm at to the grave and
how do i you know
what experiences am i putting when right
and am i am i optimizing you know people
are
are busy they're on autopilot there's a
lot of distractions going on
and the culture just has them that way
the other thing is is people are so more
or they need to move their fear they
fear
running out of money as opposed to fear
of wasting their lives
right like my i shifted my fear from
holy [ __ ] i do not want to look
backwards and be like i [ __ ] this
right up
i only got one ride and i don't want to
have a thousand wood a coat of shoulders
right or i didn't take this chance or i
didn't allocate it or have a jillion
dollars in the bank that i could have
spent or
went here or had these you know done
this charity event or hung out with my
parents or whatever
whatever it may be whoever you are right
i
that so that is my biggest fear is fear
of missing out on my own life
right i don't more than fear of running
out of money
and and that fear of missing out on my
own life leads me to model it
right if you're going to go from here to
california you're going to google maps
it you're going to waze if you're going
to put stops in you're going to put it
in it's going to figure out the
optimal route for you to do every single
thing
in your journey right but here on planet
earth our journey is the grave
we know the destination it's death so
get used to it get comfortable
that's where you're going so we need to
optimize our journey
right to get as much as we can given our
resources that we have
and so this is what this book is about
it's about optimizing your journey
so i'm reading another book about death
it's called the denial of death by
ernest becker
it's classic book i quoted in my book
losing the nobel prize because
i think it's something that uh that i
believe alfred nobel
did and he could have used your book in
a sense because
he didn't die with zero he died with
millions and millions of dollars in the
bank
and i think it's partially due to what
ernest becker calls the denial of death
that we all know as you said our final
destination
we're all going in the same place warren
buffett and the
the you know when i used to be a
dishwasher i used to think about oh i
could be like warren buffett
well nobody here gets out alive and so
the question
you know is why do we have this
abstinence this resistance to it it's
the one risk
we all know we face it's like last year
i was putting together
a risk register with my colleagues on
the simon's observatory this huge
telescope project 300 people building in
17 000 feet in the atacama desert of
chile super exciting going to transform
our understanding of the big bang and we
all put down well there's a risk that
there'll be
concrete prices will fluctuate there's a
risk the chilean peso will do this
nobody had coronavirus nobody had global
pandemic
and i wonder when you think about these
risk modeling we know that we're going
to get older our health curve is also
going to decline
i've got a sketch of it on the
blackboard over here but our health is
going to decline we know that that's a
known known
but what about all the unknown knowns
you have a very interesting and unique
perspective on how to model
these one-off risk events not like you
can buy covet insurance two years ago
but talk about the kind of hedging and
the risk management
that you offer as a solution to the
anxiety
confronting the denial of death right so
one of the things i try and get people
comfortable i and i had this
conversation with my
my in-laws like they were like oh we
want to go here and go on this trip but
we need to save money for our health
right and so like and i said well what
calamity
that you're saving for that you think
that money will cover
right either your insurance is covering
it or you're
dying like let's just be real like you
don't you're not
you're not you're not aetna you're not
aig you're not you're not any of these
so
what thread the needle like thank god i
had five thousand dollars for that right
like and so
that was one but you know talking about
the tools you know
there are is a product out there to
from people that have the law of large
numbers on their side
right making a seven percent return or
six percent return
to take the risk that you don't want to
have right so if you're worried about
longevity risk well i'm going to lift
the 200
and i'm worried about running buy an
annuity you know insure that risk out
yeah
if you're you know what i mean people
generally buy life insurance risk
they're worrying about dying early
and and not having a breadwinner for
their family so they buy
you know i'm gonna die early so they buy
life insurance but there's the opposite
of that right and so
you know i self-insure you know i'm well
the risk i'm willing to take or if i
want to if i feel like i want to be a
little bit conservative
then i'll aim to die with a thousand
dollars or two thousand dollars right
now
model and this is not like you do it one
day it's static and that's it right
you're constantly updating based
on the situation uh that you're in every
five years
every five years you recommend every
five years you can modify or if your
taste change or something's like no i
i saw something on this trip i went and
now i want to do this so you can remodel
like you can continuously update it
originally this was going to be a
program um
it should be you should do a program or
a seminar or what you know whatever
yeah and so you know that's the the
program that we have is generally macro
and it's a it's a search algorithm
right um and it it you put in these
outputs and it searches the optimal path
of spending
and and saving in order to get
experience points etc and then we have
other modules like well diminishing
returns you're not going to ski a
hundred times and
etc right like so there's all kinds of
tweaks and other people i wanted to have
like
modules that people could add in and
make this better and better but
you know in terms of risk right i i you
know there's a there's a part of the
book where i say you're not a good
insurance agent
you're just not you're just you're just
terrible at it right you have no
expertise in the risk
you don't know how likely it is to
happen and by
using hours of your life working at a
job to save up the money for
you know robot alien space invasion
insurance right
i have that here i do need that in
california
you know it's like you you're being
wasteful
it's inefficient you're much better off
paying it off to an insurance
agent to cover that risk right and
that's when i talk about annuities
right yeah people are worried about
longevity risk outliving their money
and there's there's other products right
that people use in every day and
it's not necessarily to sell annuities
it's just to get them to think about
what they're doing right because you get
a lot of resistance from people being
like well i can't take that trip now
because
what if this happens in the future i'm
like by the annuity
what about long-term care insurance buy
the long-term care insurance
i mean like it's cheaper than you
slaving away
two three years of your life to sock
away that money yeah
right absolutely uh to to cover
this calamity right and so
and so i say stop trying to be an
insurance agent with a customer of one
and they are the most right yeah yeah
the most common objection that i hear is
oh that's selfish you're not gonna give
it to your kids no the whole point is
you are you have forethought you think
about your kids
you allocate the money to them but you
point out the average age for people to
die nowadays by 81 or 82 if you're a man
maybe a little older for women and when
they die their kids are going to be in
their 50s or 60s
and to use an extreme example you know
somebody that dies at age you know 120
the biblical age
uh you know that you're supposed to wish
people to live to their kids are going
to be 90 100 years old like what are you
going to do with 100
100 you know dollars when you're their
lives are passing by and they've
deteriorated past the point where they
can actually
convert that money into experiences if
you think about it like if we
money is an abstract and it distracts
people it's like when you go into the
casino they give you chips
right right and you're just like hey
here's a tip 25 dollars let it ride like
you're just so capricious
because they gave you chips because they
turned it's like money is already an
abstraction and then they
put an abstraction upon an extraction
and turn them into chips
and then next thing you know you're
you're you're brewster's million
right like you're spending like it was
like water right and so
what happens here is that people
people need to think about what does
money represent and it represents
hours of their life that they exchanged
right
it's that's the best definition is
something we exchange
hours of our life for right days years
whatever and so when you
exchange your life for money
and don't get the experiences out of it
you're wasting your life
right you're literally wasting your life
and so when you're trying to
help your kids and give them money what
you're trying to do is help them and
give them experiences
choices that they can make right well
when can they most take advantage and
convert that money and have experiences
when is the optimal period when is the
maximum power of that gift
you want to think about that right yeah
and so when you're dying with zero
you're dying with zero your own money
not your kids money that should be
separated out
and allocated to them yeah almost
immediately it doesn't mean they get
control of it
right like my kids have their money they
can't touch it it's in a trust
right they'll get it really you're not
giving all your money to your teenage
girls right now
oh no no they're not good they'll be
going out they're being slurpees and i
don't know what they do
they just but they're going to reach
mental maturity
as most people do around 28 right
according to the science right and
physical maturity around 33
yeah right that's kind of around there
and so
somewhere around 28 to 33
is maximum impact right in terms of that
gift
after that each dollar i give them is
worth less
right to them yeah in their ability to
convert into experiences and so
you you know people might shift that
earlier or later but you basically
the thing is to actually be off
autopilot
deliberately think about what you want
to give to your kids set it aside so if
you get in an accident and get sued
you don't you don't vaporize the kids
money it's their money right
that also frees you to take risks right
a lot of times
i used to take flying lessons and ride a
motorcycle right
and then i had a baby and i was like you
know what i'm okay with this risk but i
don't have the right to take the risk
from my kids
right yeah so i like to gamble i like to
travel i trade big i take all kinds of
risks but i have the right to take the
risk for my kids
right that i put them in this
environment so their money is set aside
in a trust right you could put you he is
yeah you could you could actually take
the and the one thing i took away
because i am a pilot i i fly
you know uh engines you know dual
engines i always have a flight
instructor with me etc so i minimize the
risk
but um one point i took away is yeah you
could take out life insurance so god
forbid you get killed
in a plane accident but you can't take
out experience insurance
there's no such thing so my kids would
get denied that
and i i look at it and i came away with
a resonance with what you said
i'm i'm a practicing jewish person and
every friday night we have a certain
number we have
shabbat where we get together we have a
family meal
it's a it's a type of experience and
bonding that we have i figured out
not too hard to calculate 18 years at
home
uh 52 weeks a year multiply those
together that means i get a thousand
shabboses with each one of my kids
that's it so that means
if i'm going to go you know speak at the
bill perkins conference in
west virgin islands uh it better be
worth more than point one percent right
because that's one
shabbos out of the thousand i'm gonna
lose and i have to exchange that if i'm
gonna be
not working but if i'm gonna be away
from my family away from my wife and
kids
i think about that but you crystallized
it in this
in this book in terms of building up
experiences experiences
and attention are the least fungible of
all resources and i find it really
fascinating
that you go through and you actually you
take issue with steve jobs i don't know
if you
if you know this but steve jobs never
gave away his money
while he was alive um are you aware of
that
no yeah he never gave up i mean yeah he
said i'm a better investor than anybody
will be
and putting the money in apple computer
will make them more money than uh
than they could use if i gave it to them
now so i'm a better uh
at investing but you basically except
they are starving and dying right now
exactly
exactly yes anybody anybody who's been
you know rushed to the hospital knowing
that they're gonna die or didn't have
the ambulance care you know et cetera
it's like okay it's too late you know i
don't know what future humans you're
helping and maybe
it's work but like you know charity is
now life is now life is urgent and
i just haven't seen a return better than
education and helping people currently
yeah yeah i say travel travel is a form
of education
you can buy you can buy iq points by
traveling and it seems like you do that
you're you're on these trips these
extravagances i want to ask you
you have an interesting backstory you
started as an energy trader if i'm not
mistaken
uh talk about like what did that give
you what tools did that give you
and what is um i have the psychological
theory that maybe you're uh
you know you're so into poker because
you've actually hedged your risk so well
in your life
that there's still this need this
anxiety that you do want to gamble in
some way because you're not gambling
stupidly with your money you're super
brilliant about that
but like why do you gamble what does it
attract to you are is it possible you
can get addicted to it
i think there is a i think it's a puzzle
i think there's addiction to winning and
getting lucky like you want the feeling
of getting lucky right
like you know blackjack's against you
people play you know craps against you
you just love that like i got lucky yeah
look at the casino it's like this palace
how do you think they got the money for
it
yeah it's this form of entertainment and
and social aspect of it
that i think may may have been missing
but i think you know going into energy
and being exposed to you know people who
were when i was
dead broke and they were having large
sums of money
you know it really forced me to ask the
questions of but why
and what for and you know most of the
people were older and i was younger and
so i had a distorted view of what old
was
right i would be like who cares if
you're a millionaire you're old
you know what i mean like right they'd
be my age now right
what are you gonna do with it drive your
kid to school you know what i mean like
you know i'd just be like the most
arrogant
you know snobby snotty look at these
older rich people i was like i got to
get rich before 30 and a lot of people
want to get rich
young there's a reason for that i mean
even though
my ageism was was wrong in magnitude it
was in the right direction
right i don't i don't i was like well
i'm working hard to be a billionaire by
the age of 90.
what what am i gonna you know be like
what am i gonna do with that you know
what i mean and so
that put me on the course to figure out
okay when is the optimal age
right when is the when is when does
money have the most fun
at that time was just fun when do i get
the most girls and when do i have the
most fun
but you know later in life it's like
when does it have the most utility for
me
right how does my life order it's like
is
is is it better to be rich after you're
married or before you're married
you know like things like that like and
how does the ordering of your life go
and how does it place and there and then
i was like well when i was a baby it was
useless and when i'm 90 it's useless so
like you said in the beginning of
conversation there's this
there must be a curve right there's got
to be a utility curve and like well how
am i going to figure this out i need an
economist and a mathematician come over
here and help me
i need some health professionals to talk
to me about you know
frailty curse and bone frailty and bone
density and lung capacity
and watts per kilograms to climb a
stairs
like one time i was reading this article
researching this
and it didn't make it into the book but
it talked about the watts per kilogram
you need to climb a flight of stairs
and how you know your muscles atrophy
and etc and after you get to a certain
level you can't climb a flight of stairs
right and how much energy you have and
so i was like wow
and i read this book by i don't know if
you know james uh jay gould james gould
yeah he wrote deep hop biosphere yep
it's one
it's one of my favorite books whether
whether the theory is right or not
um in the beginning he's talking about
life and how
all living things are energy processing
units
and and i talk about this in the book
and machines are energy processing units
and when you are no longer able to
process energy you die
you're declared dead right and so and
when a machine can't process energy it's
broken it's getting like it's
it's done and so and that allows that
processing of energy allows you to fire
your neurons fire your muscles and
allows you to propel you
through our universe right in this
organic spacesuit that we have to have
all these experiences
and so it hit me real hard so i took
that i was like [ __ ]
movement is life processing
energy is life the more energy you are
processing
the more life you get right in the
broadest terms
right yeah and so i thought [ __ ] if i
can't move around
i have less life when my body starts to
deteriorate and i can't process the
energy and i can't climb downstairs i
have less light which is true
because when i went to st petersburg
it's great beautiful city i like to walk
around
they let you climb these 210 steps and
walk around the churches and look around
it's like wow they never let you do that
in new york city or never you know like
for all the rest reasons you would say
right and i noticed the tour buses that
were lined up not a single
one of those tour bus people got off and
climbed the stairs
and when it hit me and i was like
st petersburg is not the same st
petersburg to me i'm getting a 10 st
petersburg
because i'm able to explore more and
climb these steps and see this view
and do this whatever for them they're
getting a six right
in absolute terms relative it's a 10 for
them because they're doing what they can
do right now but i'm just saying like
maybe they should have came to st
petersburg in their 50s
as opposed to their 70s right yeah and
so
life is like tetris you got to get the
order right in order to get the high
score right god goes
in the beginning you're up in heaven
it's like here is the bucket
of experiences you can have on earth
it's a
giant ass bucket okay you're like great
and he goes but you got to get the order
right or else you don't get all of them
that's right right and i and i think a
lot of people are
are are going through life not thinking
about the order of these things and
getting these things allocated
and these resources applied at the right
time so they don't get
the maximum out of the bucket that god
has given them yeah
and i think about that um that really
resonates with me
as a as a jewish person again there's a
famous rabbi now rabbis in eastern
europe you know in the 1800s
they weren't known for you know going
wakeboarding and i don't know if they
are now it is
uh but there's a famous rabbi rabbi uh
uh samson raphael hirsch and he said
almost on his deathbed he told his
students he said
uh my students take me to uh on your
backs and carry me up to the alps he was
in
you know germany or near switzerland
he's like and they're like what are you
talking about
like why do you want to go to the alps
like that's not a very jewish thing to
do are you going to go skiing
snowboarding get some uh get some ollies
and he said no
god made this beautiful world and i'm
going to die in a few years and i'm
going to be up in heaven he's going to
ask me why didn't you see my beautiful
alps i made them for you
i made them just for you and i i got
that i got the chills when i was reading
your book
because it's the same philosophy god
made this world whoever you whoever made
this world is it more mysterious if you
create it it's to me they're both
miracles
in a way i had a wonderful conversation
with uh with a physicist earlier this
week
and and we were just talking about like
there are some things that are mysteries
of life and there are some things of
puzzles
what's the difference between a mystery
and a puzzle well a mystery might not
have a solution
a puzzle you might not be able to solve
but somebody smarter than you could
solve it
and again i'm thinking about like games
and and the enjoyment and
uh correct me if i'm wrong but when
you're playing poker you're doing all
your crazy stuff with that guy dan
balzerian i guess is his name
i don't know anything about him um are
you in that flow state that you just you
just crave like the poker
like you already said you need a team to
play poker you need people to play poker
you're obviously a team player you
played football in iowa in college
that's probably responsible for your
knee
uh but uh well first of all actually
would you trade that experience like
would you have a little more cartilage
in your knee
and forego those awesome experience of
being a college scholarship athlete at a
top premier
football school i walked on walked on
but yeah i i don't know i i'm actually
now that like i'm you know it's a
it's hard it's hard not being able to
run the sim on your life
what would happen the relationships you
had the friendships you made etc
to say oh you know i wipe those over and
do it over for the cartilage i'll be
like
you know for the friends and the love
that i had i'd give them a piece i'd
give up the cartilage
and i would give up that piece right
because the memory dividend and we
didn't talk that much about it but you
know
when you when you invest in the bank
right you you get interest
right yeah and and and you can get a
certain amount of money out and withdraw
it
when you invest in an experience when
you recall that experience you get
a portion of the joy sometimes the joy
is actually greater than the original
experience but sometimes there's a great
portion of it sometimes it's just a
little bit
right tell the story of your first kiss
recall the time you got married
your daughter's graduation the first
time she was in a school play
and delivered whatever it is right
whatever experience it is and then
you get that dividend you get the
neurons firing you get the endorphins
you relive it and that's called the
memory dividend
it's it's an experience in itself and so
those memory dividends right
have been paying themselves for years
and years and years and years
and sometimes they compound right yeah i
tell the story about
a football thing the other guy goes yeah
with the hawkeye whatever we start
a friendship and boom a new experience
off the memory dividend
going on and so that has to go into the
calculus
of how you live your life and when you
allocate having any kind of experience
whether it be charitable
or hedonistic right and so
you know the one thing i like to say is
when you invest in a bank there's only
so many so much you can withdraw
an interest yeah when you're that's an
experience it's infinite
yeah you can go there all the time yeah
and i i i tell a off-caller joke i was
like ask anybody who masturbates
ask anybody who masturbates about the
memory dividend they get a little a
little more kosher example
of that yeah exactly no i don't it's so
and so um
you know but anybody who hit a home run
like how many times have you heard
you know you get it that's memory
dividends in action
right and that's the stuff of life
that's what you're gonna retire on
right when you can no longer move and
you're sick of watching jeopardy for
that day
you're going to reminisce on the
adventures
decisions choices that you made
throughout your life
so you need to make sure that you invest
heavily
in these experiences so that you reach
you have a retirement
and the earlier the better is your
retirement right yeah
exactly the earlier the better as well
like the i always envy my
friends that had kids in their 20s you
know i didn't have kids until i was 30s
in my 30s
and you know looking back on it and you
know this because you're an engineer by
training and
you know a lot about it but uh but most
people can't comprehend exponentials and
that's why
einstein thought of compound growth is
so interesting you know one of my
friends who i've had on the show
um alex hayne he's a big time youtuber
uh he he makes the point let's say you
want to lose 10 pounds in a year
okay and you're gonna lose one percent a
day so you're gonna lose like
one percent of the 10 pounds a day but
you're going to keep compounding that so
that's going to grow and grow and grow
so as you know the rule of 72 right they
haven't repealed that rule right
so you take you take the number 72 you
divide into the interest rates that's
how many days or doubling
our time the doubling period is going to
be now so if you have one percent that
means it's going to double in 72 days
how many doubling periods are there in a
year well there's 365 divided by 72
let's call it five doubling periods
that means your money or whatever is
going to double five times
in a year so that means 3 200 2 to the
30 sorry 32 2 to the fifth power
so 32 x now apply that to losing weight
that means if you're losing 10 pounds in
the last
72 days you're going to lose half the
weight
like that's just the way the doublings
work right so every period so that means
in the first doubling period the first
72 days almost three months you're going
to lose like a couple of ounces
that's all and you're not even going to
know you can have a beer with dan
bilzerian
and you're going to blow it away but
think about it if you start early
that means that that last period of time
which is in your life the life bucket
where you're about to die
the last five ten years you're gonna
double that memories all the memories
you've ever had in your life
it's really magical and i agree with
einstein you know he he had a pretty
good uh he was a pretty good guy
he was a pretty smart guy this guy
einstein he had he had a good view
he had an interesting perspective on
things so yeah i i
i i'm like listen using the power of
compound interest
and you know like when you hear warren
buffett and these guys talk about
investing like invest early
early early right because you want to
take advantage of compound interest
i'm like experiences investor early
early early take advantage of the
compound interest
of memory dividends they are a real
thing there's a lot of neuron science
out there that goes on when you drink a
coke you don't just drink the coke you
drink all the commercials and good times
when they're
when you have a meal with food science
right when you have a meal like you have
shabbat right when you have shabbat not
only do you have that experience
but you're having the shabbat of all the
shabbat all the culture all the history
all the memories etc right it's playing
into that current thing and then it goes
on
and it produces its dividend and
compounds on so on so
i'm like take advantage of that and see
how it applies in your life
right yeah to whatever experience you
want to have and so
it's not like hey do this do that it's
have the mental model
right to create and model your own
adventure
so that when you get to the end you die
with zero regrets yeah right die
with zero a practical basis what is
what is a how do you go through this
risk matrix or this end by n matrix
or whatever let's say i'm inviting you
to come speak at this imagination
conference
you know i'm going to pull you off the
boat i'm going to pay you you know
you're going to have some money but
let's be honest we don't do everything
we do for money i mean that's like
the least of why we do what we do you're
doing it for this book is not about
money this is this is about saving lives
yeah i mean
this book is a bestseller gotten it's
top count it's not like number one new
york times but that's not why you did it
that's not why you gave away all these
free resources like i'm linking to on
the web page right now
um but uh but there's other forms of
remuneration
that and so my question to you is like
how do you differentiate like
okay so we know we're not gonna die with
work with millions of dollars in the
bank
um you know thanks to the stock market
performance today no no but uh we're not
and i'm a state employee i'm just a
simple state employee of the california
state
but um but what about the other
experiences you know the the
like there is a high you get from being
with this guy that i keep hearing about
or or you get this high for being in a
poker
at some level you have to be honest
you're
sorry i'm just watching the the
background behind you there
uh but but at some level you're gonna
have to trade
attention to your kids or or whatever
and and so how do you go through that
rank ordering yourself
i mean it's it's very difficult because
i i try and i try and say okay what are
my priorities
i try and get in touch with my a lot of
times the first thing i do i got to slap
myself get off autopilot
right because a lot of it's just like go
do this or whatever somebody invites you
yes go
you know i mean not thinking about how
does this fit in the grid
and where is the time i've allocated for
it right so you can constantly you can
wind up in
over allocating your time to certain
things that you normally wouldn't while
you're on autopilot so the first thing
you just slap myself off autopilot
see what my priorities are and see how
they conflict
right like because we all have
conflicting priorities right i want to
have fun i might have a great time i
want to be a great dad
i want to you know i mean i want to do
this i want to play poker you know so
sometimes these conflict and we have to
like
be aware and rectify them and a lot of
times
like in certain decisions you know like
you know
speaking of dan like he's like why are
you leaving we're out here in
india why are you going back to go to a
soccer game flying 12 hours i was like
dan i made that decision 16 years ago
i didn't know it but that was a dynamic
decision
that i made 16 years ago right so i'm
not deciding now
i already decided right so a lot of
times it's just me getting aligned with
my priorities
right and and and
and behaving in that way but it's you
know sometimes i use
future regret when i look back on this
time period will i think
this way you know i use a lot of mental
tools and tricks to get in there
and one of them is just modeling my life
from now to the grave and i allocate and
i say okay what am i going to do here
what i'm going to do here went over here
and i look
at it when i'm in a clear space right
these five years or these three years
this year
this whatever and then i go oh this
doesn't fit
this would be nice to do but it doesn't
fit it's not here it's it's in conflict
with my the arc of my life now i can re
i can change that any time but i don't
want to i don't want to be willy-nilly
about it
flapping in the wind based on
circumstances on there i want to find my
true north
my priorities and my goals and i want to
kind of
i want to kind of stay into that you
know absolutely i want to ask you
difficult it's very difficult right we
live in a
we we live in a paradox of choice right
we have a lot of choices right it's not
like
hey we're going to do today i'm going to
farm and i'm going to you know
melt the cows pray to my god
we have the paradox of choice now so
yeah it's not easy i'm not saying it's
easy
but it's you know a model is better than
no model
absolutely and we'll have links to that
i just want to remind everybody we're
talking to bill perkins uh who is a
legend in the uh financial industry
he's an all-around awesome guy friend of
the show and friend of james altucher
good friend of the show
this is a brian keating's into the
impossible podcast or
talking about all sorts of things
different from my normal science fair so
make sure as bill recommends get your
exercise exercise your finger right now
press the subscribe button press the
like button and subscribe to this
channel and then go over and press the
click
die with zero website that i put up as
well and buy this book this book is
awesome
it'll change your life it doesn't matter
how much money you have i've getting
some questions for you bill i hope you
have a few more minutes to answer a
couple audience questions
awesome okay so he wants to know uh my
fri one of my listeners ralph
wants to know have you thought have you
considered um you know some of the
uh the writings or teachings of jordan
peterson
uh how does that play in if at all into
your life into your thinking
uh he's a very religious guy as well as
i understand super controversial i
haven't read much of his stuff
but he talks about entropy and chaos and
and what do you feel about that
well i i feel entropy is inevitable
right but i haven't read i haven't read
his i haven't read his work so that's
the first
that's the first answer the first blunt
answer is but if you talk about
entertaining and chaos and trying to
make
order and sense of the world this is
like you know from my perspective it's
you do your best
that's all you can do so if we're
eventually gonna get swallowed up by the
sun right
and then you know everything is gonna
you know
explode and then everything's gonna go
dark right if you're a big
big if you're a big crunch guy then
everything's gonna become hell
or if everything's gonna become ice
that'll be our next podcast bill okay
right now stick to your book right like
stick to your book absolute zero that's
the point of it all and i
i think the point of it is to do your
best and enjoy yeah right and enjoy the
ride and so
regardless of entropy chaos
circumstances right is to maintain the
attitude that i am going to do my best
and be stoic about it
yeah i found that also to be a theme
running through the book that we are
gonna reach our end i'm gonna have ryan
holiday on the show
hopefully in the next few months and he
talks about this it's like it doesn't
matter if you win this nobel
medallion uh a real one or you've got
you know a million dollars in bitcoin
just sitting there
you're all going to the same place and
what's that i can't see that
that is my death date this is the
entropy right like that is the estimate
of the day i'm gonna die and it's
counting down backwards ah okay it's to
come to grips with
yeah just just confront it so one of my
listeners is wondering
how do you handle extreme risks so you
obviously you take some risks you're
prudent
but i know you've done podcasts about
bitcoin and
all these other things uh energy trading
i mean you were doing options futures
derivatives
um we've had on jim simons on my podcast
before you know the king of the quants
the the original quan
um how do you deal with extreme risk
like i would think
you wouldn't want to be dealing with
bitcoin um as you're
you you've spoken about another podcast
like james's podcast but uh
yeah go for it which category so
financially i i've always been
comfortable with taking extreme risks
right the leverage because i when i
looked at it right when i was
screen clerk driving limo at night
trying to make ends meet right
i was like wow i can be a waiter and
have a better life right like i can have
i can make more money
and i look at the safety systems and the
jobs around i was like i can always
drive a garbage truck
i can always do this right so i always
looked at the downside as
i'm surviving i'm i'm having a great
time as a broke
kid now i'm surviving you know i'm
having a great time parks are free i can
walk i can hike
i can hack i can spend my my time
hacking trips and
you know figuring ways to live the ride
at my level
and so i was always like maximum
maximum financial risk of which i've
gone broke twice
so that happens uh you know when you're
doing that
in terms of finance physical risk right
that i am allowed to take
etc i always look at the reward and it's
an equation for me
so i like riding motorcycles right and
i think if you drive a motorcycle for a
year i think the odds of dying is one in
ten thousand
if you drive every day or whatever
that's right a thousand and i'm like but
i don't drive a motorcycle so i use that
i was like
is this more enjoyable than riding a
motorcycle
yes okay then i could take maybe i could
take motorcycle type risk one in ten
thousand right
if it's less enjoyable than riding a
motorcycle
and it's one in nine thousand i'm not
doing it you know what i mean so for
each person
and you know with their risk reward
ratio they have to figure out what
they're comfortable with
and and and kind of find a metric right
like kind of find where they're at
like i if i like cigarettes enough i
would smoke them
i don't like them enough i don't want to
take the risk you know for me
everything's risk reward
um that being said i generally encourage
people to take
as much risk as they possibly can stand
as much as they can and then add a
little more i tend to believe that is a
more adventurous fulfilling life and i
think
it's all about net fulfillment over net
worth
right yeah and so that that is my and
and that that can be saying i love you
first
right that's scary sometimes right
that's a big risk for some people
that could be from a city to another
city that you're unfamiliar with to go
take this job or just take this
adventure et cetera
right it could be it could be it could
be a lot of things right that that are
risky to people so i
i'm like you know as much as you can
look at how much wish you can take and
just add a little bit more
yeah that's fascinating that's that
could be your mod or your next your next
motto add a little bit more you know
it's uh yeah homer simpson once said
or actually see montgomery burns who's
homer's boss
yeah i love that he once said um you
know homer said you're super rich
you know and he goes yes but i trade
everything for just a little bit more
i thought that was funny um uh
so i i have a question from one of my
listeners esquire
he's wondering a lot of us take care of
our parents not only our kids
and i wonder for on his behalf i have a
question about kids from another
listener in hawaii but um
but this listener's wondering uh you
know how do you deal with that because
they're closer you know i used to say my
late father when he was alive
he used to say like you got to come to
me because my time is worth more than
your time
uh you know because he didn't have that
much left and it turned out to be true
unfortunately
but um for those of us that are
struggling taking care of young kids
taking care of old parents
how do you how do you deal with that
those confounding risks i mean just to
be
extreme your daughter says i want you to
come to my tennis game
and your mom or your nana or whatever
says i i need to see you i wanna i wanna
hang out with you too just not not that
they need you but
how do you how do you play it off yeah i
i i
i mean it's it's i use future
so you know in that scenario for me
to get to a decision i would be like my
dad's dead my daughter's still here did
i have the right time with him whatever
like i would use some sort of i i really
love
zero and i really love infinity because
when i put things at zero infinity it
helps me get perspective
right i can find out things in the
beginning right and so
with the with the dad and the daughter
scenario given okay
move time forward 50 years dad's dead
you're about to die
whatever are you happy that you
chose your dog go spend time with your
daughter at that moment than your dad or
not
and each person might have a different
answer but i'm just saying that that
would help me get to the decision
you know i i was taking care of my dad
during his last years
um and you know
model it's part of the model right it's
part of the model like
okay this is the money that i've set
aside to take care of dad
or a percentage of my earnings or
whatever this is the money that's going
percentage of my earnings that's going
to the kids
the rest is for me to model for me to
the grave right and so
the more you compartmentalize and model
the more efficient you'll be with your
resources
and their resources as well yeah i'm
putting up on the screen i've got a list
uh i've got your um
uh the mental models free workbook which
i've gone through and i thank you so
much for doing i thought it was
important to do it
during uh this time thanksgiving time
etc people thinking about the end of the
year and
trying to get a leg up uh last question
i have before i get to some more of my
listener questions i don't know if you
know this guy garyvee
but this guy's like yes i'm hustling i'm
sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna dump on him a
little bit i'm not that he's ever gonna
hear those but
but you know he's like i'm always
hustling like you always see the guy
he's always like this
like on his phone and i know you got
like all these prop bets with people
like uh balzarian and other people about
not using your phone
or else you get a ten thousand dollar an
hour fine above
five hours a day uh i think that's
awesome i like all these bets for losing
weight i gotta get you on a prop bet so
i can
get a six pack at least right before i
die uh but um yeah but gary vee
it's like hustling like i gotta do this
why are you doing this and even kevin
hart even your buddy kevin hart
he said uh you know i'm doing this why
am i doing these tours
for my kids i just think that they're
not being honest with themselves bill i
mean i think
they're doing it for themselves at some
level yes they have so much money i mean
the difference between kevin hart
and bill gates is functionally zero they
can both do
exactly the same things with their money
uh and because you know there's only so
as as gordon gekko said or or
charlie sheen said to gordon gekko how
many yachts
yeah and you're you're on one now i i
know you got two water skis back there
but
i you know i i never
try to like tell people oh they're
working for nothing but i do
got them to identify it i had a friend
who was like
risking and trading and uh he's i was
like you got to get the yacht you got to
get the shot you got to get a bigger
yacht you have the money you get a yacht
and he's like well i lost the yacht
trading this this month it was a bad
month whatever and i said so you risked
the yacht
for what what was the bigger thing
you were going to get and he was like
good point
right so there always has to be
something out there that you're working
so
if they can identify what it is
then i'm okay with it i'm not gonna you
know what i mean they could say i want
to buy the nation in namio whatever you
want to be like
i don't know what really is or what
their goals are or whatever i can tell
you
if you buy a yacht it's pretty expensive
you're gonna need a lot more money than
just the purchase price
i know i don't buy a cheap yacht i did
that once i bought a cheap yacht but
that you know there's a saying that that
that boat is so cheap i can't afford it
correct that that's that's yachts and
planes in general
but um you know i i do believe that
much like you know kevin has a a
glorious job and he loves it he loves
being a comedian he loves making people
laugh he loves the limelight
those are the type of people so i think
there's part of that but i also think
there's part of it
in everybody where they get habituated
right whatever they're doing and so
they're like they start
making up reasons why they're doing it
you know as opposed to the original
reason right like a rat in the wheel
who's not getting cheese he's like i
like running in the wheel i like running
in the wheel
no no no we conditioned you to run in
the wheel yeah you got a chapter it's
like
but i like this job i'm getting in shape
and
then it gets my lungs going and i love
running into this wheel right that's
what the rat's thinking right you're
going
no dude we conditioned you right
and so i think there's a lot of that
going on
in everybody myself included right like
they're just like no i love my job and
the people and the co-workers and and
the water cooler and the thing and i'm
just like no no
no no no no no that is not what your
dream is
you did not have this as your dream this
is not
either the universe of things you can be
doing this is not your goal
who are you kidding get off autopilot
right and so
um it happens to all of us and we just
make up reasons why we're doing it
you know yeah i agree you have actually
a section it's like but i love my job
it's just so awesome to read this
because i'm reading this book and i'm
thinking like but wait i've got this
objection that bill's never thought of
believe me bill's thought of everything
in this book everybody i want you to get
this book die with zero
it's got graphs for this for my techno
nerds out there of which there are many
got to get the graphs got to solve the
optimization problem do the derivative
of this it'll be a
homework exercise i i just think as
you're saying that bill
you know one of my uh one of my favorite
things to notice is when somebody let's
say somebody retires or gets really
fired
they say i'm gonna spend more time with
my family and then they they come back
because they're young they come back to
some other job like meg whitman or
something
like what you got tired of your family
like like why did you come back
did they get tired of you i i i should
write another
book or have a book like on interviewing
people and what's going on but
my theory is this is that you're 17 18
19 20
you have all these dreams the things you
want to do experiences you want to have
whatever and then you go out into the
world
to go acquire the funds and resources to
do those things
somewhere along the way you get
disconnected
and the job becomes the goal not the
things you wanted but the job
right i'm good at what i do i just keep
doing i gotta close another deal or sell
another house or
whatever run another company if you're
meg whitman et cetera and
that becomes an end of itself and if we
disassociated
from ourselves after 10 or 15 years or
20 years of doing this thing
you know you spent a lot of time a lot
of hours a lot of
waking hours getting good at that but
how many hours did you spend
learning how to socialize learning how
to travel learning how to interact with
your family
learning how to get in touch with
whatever you forget it and it's a skill
you need to work on it that's why when
people retire like i don't know what to
do with myself
you know what i mean i'm like that's
because all you've been doing is running
in the goddamn wheel
that's right like a hamster you're just
like and you're just like i just want to
go back in the wheel can i go back in
the wheel can i run in the wheel
you know because that's what they're
using you don't even have to give me
cheese i don't even need the cheese
anymore just
give me the [ __ ] wheel who moved my
just give me the [ __ ] wheel i've been
doing the wheel for [ __ ] 15 years i
just want to be
in the wheel you know and and that's
what happens to us and the wheel is
everything it's the educational system
it's the job system it's the retirement
system
uh but this book is a psychology book i
want to commend you you don't have
training in that
but you are a stealth psychologist and
there's a lot of references in this book
die with zero i can't commend it to you
highly enough
it'll appeal to the technologist or the
total luddite technologically speaking
i've referred it to many many people
it's one of my top gifts of the year is
going to be this book so please
follow bill online bill if you've got
another minute and a half i want to ask
you the final questions i ask all my
guests is that okay
okay yeah that's fine okay good so the
first question i have is can you unify
quantum gravity with space-time
dynamics in a way that will be quantum
mechanically coherent
in all space-time integrals
in two years okay good okay all right
real quick can you unify quantum
quantum mechanics and gravity the funny
thing is
i've thought about that every time
there's an article out that's kind of
there i go read it but it's not there
the string theory guys think they have
it i
i don't know subscribe to my channel
bill this is a this a plug we talk about
theories of everything
nobel prize winners etc but my serious
question for you
is um there's a concept in judaism
called the ethical will
it's what you give to your children not
only your biological children your
ideological children the people that you
mentor of which you have many
and i want to ask you what wisdom or
something would you put not your
material will because you're not going
to leave anything
it's going to be all zeroed out by the
time you hit the grave at 120 but when
you hit that magical biblical age
what do you want to leave in terms of
wisdom for future generations to heed to
um i i would think like the main thing
people always ask like oh what would you
tell your 20 20 year old self that's
coming that's coming
i i would say uh forgiveness
forgiveness forgiveness and the most
important person you need to forgive is
yourself
we're the hardest on ourselves and it
puts us into shame
and shame and addiction they're
interchangeable
no one knows where shame begins and
addiction starts or rejection ends and
shame begins
they're just all wrapped up in there you
know you want to say you want to be
i've done a bad thing not i am a bad
person right and that's a
that's a monumental difference right or
i am stupid no you're not stupid you did
a stupid thing
right and so that that keeps people from
becoming scientists or astrophysicists
right as opposed to oh i just got a bad
grade on this test i just did poorly i
didn't study or whatever
so that is the number one thing and
other people
so that's it yeah great yeah i always
say einstein wasn't always einstein you
know when he was a baby you know he was
he was he didn't have this mustache when
he was a baby right um last question
then
is um you ever see the movie 2001 a
space odyssey
a couple times yes so you know there's
an opening scene with these animals
these apes or primates or whatever
and they chuck this thing up in the air
and they discover this monolith
and this monolith is like a time capsule
meant to encapsulate
human knowledge to our knowledge from
some alien civilization
years billions of years in the past i
want to ask you if i gave you a time
capsule here i made it at ucsd
give you a time capsule i'd say bill
it's going to last for a billion years
and if i did that to you what would you
put on the time capsule in the time
capsule what do you think is most worth
preserving about the human species or
the planet earth
wow you can encapsulate like what am i
going to encapsulate
in there well i don't want to stick
anybody in there to be like wait wait i
wanted to live in this pier time period
you know so what
what i would try and find acts of
kindness
and helping you know i would i would i i
think that is like
i think the greatest thing about humans
is that we are a social empathetic
animal no other animal cares the monkeys
the gorillas on one hill don't care
about the gorillas on the other hand
they're not worried if they're starving
or they have enough bananas
they don't give a [ __ ] they don't care
it's like it's not their problem
not their circus not their monkeys i
like to say right like and so
but but humans do and they're empathetic
and they're in there and they
and they're and they and they have a
plight like if you're hurting i'm
hurting
right and so i would want to somehow
stick that quality
in there and be like for future super
intelligent people i hope you have
some of this right i hope you have some
of this
i hope you do too and uh i want to thank
you for this book it's a gift
uh to to the human race i hope everybody
out there buys it i've got a link to the
website
mental models are available 23 pages i
read it i worked on it you can see it
here
it's actually the ideal thing to do
tomorrow thanksgiving because it'll make
you give thanks to what you're actually
most
what's most important to you and i'll
make you focus on what's important so go
through print out the mental models
print out the time box you can actually
see what bills are bill actually listed
his here
on this piece of paper so you'll be able
to fill that out you'll be able to get
to know bill perkins a little bit better
but bill i want to thank you so much for
going into the impossible with me
i know uh we didn't know each other
before this but i want to thank you for
a wonderful gift that i am now in turn
going to pay it forward
and uh allow many of my friends to die
with xero thanks to your wonderful
awesome book thank you so much
i'm i'm so glad you got value out of it
and i'm very happy that other people
will too
thank you thank you bill